[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى هذه الساعه من العربيه
نتابع فيها تغطيه التداعيات الزلزال الذي
ضرب اجزاء من تركيا وسوريا ونبداها
بالعناوين
رابع ايام الكارثه نحو ثمانيه عشر الف
قتيلا في زلزال تركيا وسوريا وبحث مستمر
عن النجم
سوريا تتنفس انباء عن عبور اول قافله
مساعدات الى المناطق المتضرره والترقب
للمزيد
[تصفيق]
مواطن تركي في قريه البستان في قهرمان
مرعش بعد 84 ساعه
قضاها تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
رابع ايام الكارثه تتواصل اعمال البحث
والانقاذ في المناطق المنكوبه في شمال
سوريا وجنوب تركيا اكثر من
17,500 ضحيه حتى الان في البلدين وعشرات
الالاف من الجرحى وارقام مجهوله عن
المفقودين تعاطف عالمي وفرق انقاذ من عده
دول وجسور جويه لاغاثه المتضررين
الينا من الظلام وفد العربيه اولا عبد
المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن مرحبا بك معنا
الان كيف تتحرك قافله المساعدات
الانسانيه السعوديه بعد وصول اول طائرتين
ضمن الجسر السعودي
الذي من المنتظر كذلك وصول طائرات اخرى
خلال الايام القادمه
نعم خالد بالفعل ما ان وصلت هذه الطائرتين
المحملتين الاولى بخبراء من مختلف
التخصصات سواء كانت طبيه او الاغاثيه
وايضا فريق لمقتصيب مركز الملك سلمان يقيم
الاوضاع والحاجه الى مساعدات اكثر ونوعيه
هذه المساعدات بالاضافه الى الطائره
الاخرى التي حملت عدد كبير من المساعدات
اللوائيه الغذائيه والطبيه وكافه انواع
المساعدات التي تم تنسيق مع الجانب التركي
حيالها بالاضافه الى ذلك ما ان وصل هذا
الوافد السعودي حتى بدات الاجتماعات مع
الافاد وهي الجهه التركيه المنظمه لعمل
كافه المنظمات الاغاثيه
للاتفاق على كيفيه
واماكن وجود هذه الفرق خصوصا وانه خلال
هذه الساعات ربما ساعات القليله القادمه
يتوقع ان يتم وصول الى اضنه عدد كبير جدا
من المعدات الاليات التي ستستخدم في
عمليات البحث والانقاذ وهي معدات للدفاع
المدني السعودي بالاضافه الى تواجد عدد
كبير من خبراء الدفاع المدني السعودي
المختصين بعمليات الانقاذ وعددهم اكثر من
50 سيبداون
بالتواجد يوم غد مباشره لاستعدادا لوصول
هذا العدد الكبير من الخبراء والعدد
الكبير ايضا من المعدات
للبدع فعليا بعمليات البحث والانقاذ
مباشره في الاماكن الاكثر تضررا بالاضافه
الى ذلك كان هنالك اجتماعات موسعه
لمركز الملك سلمان مع عدد من الاطراف
وتحدثون عن الجانب السوري لعمليه ايصال
هذه المساعدات الى الداخل السوري وهنا
نتحدث عن المفاضله ما بين المعبرين سواء
كان عبر انطاكيا او حتى غازي عنتاب
والدخول الى سوريا مباشره وربما خلال
الساعات القليله القادمه مباشره ستصل هذه
المساعدات عبر متعهدين ومنظمات ومؤسسات
اغاثيه سيتم ادخال هذه المساعدات مباشره
الى سوريا عبر هذه المنافذ اذا المركز
الملك سلمان يعمل وفق اليه متبعه لبعد
بالتنسيق مع الجانب التركي وايضا الجهات
العامله في سوريا على اغاثه المتضررين
بالاضافه الى ذلك خالد في هذا المكان
تحديدا
تواجدت قبل ساعات في وتحدثت مع القائم
بالاعمال السعودي في تركيا الذي قال بانه
تم اجلاء ما يقارب خمسه واربعين مواطن
ومواطنه سعوديين في هذا المكان تحديدا في
هذا الفندق بعد ان كانوا متواجدين في
اماكن متفرقه في ضربها هذا الزلزال بعض
منهم تعرض للاصابات والبعض الاخر استطاع
ان يتم اجلائه او حتى هو ان ياتي مباشره
الى مقر تواجد السفاره والعلي استضيف سيده
سعوديه كانت متواجده تم اجلائها
واستضافتها الان من قبل السفاره السعوديه
في تركيا عارفين باسمك وحدثينا عن الساعات
الحرجه التي عشتها خلال الضرب هذا الزلزال
وضربه للمنطقه التي تتواجدين فيها ايمان
السفيان الزلزال الساعه 4:00 الفجر احنا
كنا نايمين
وبيتي بالطابقه الرابع
فكانت لحظات يعني صعبه يعني مرعبه جدا
مباشره سقط المنزل وش اللي حصل فيه سقط
الحركه الاهتزاز الصوت البيت يعني الاساس
كان يطيح بالبيت يعني
وبعد كذا وين توجهت خلال الساعات الاولى
من هذا الزلزال للسياره يعني طلعنا للشارع
وقعدنا بالسياره ثلاث ايام احنا ننام
بالسياره في اي منطقه مدينه غازان طيب متى
بداتي بالتواصل مع السفاره وكيف كانت
الامور معك حتى هذه اللحظه
تواصلت معاهم من يومين
كانت الاستجابه الله يعطيهم العافيه جدا
رائعه يعني وصاروا يطمن علي كل شويه لحد
ما وصلت عندهم وحجزوا على حسابهم شيء يعني
مجهودات يشكر عليها الله يعطيهم العافيه
الحمد لله على سلامتك وشكرا جزيلا لك اذا
خالد كما تشاهد في هذا الموقع الكثير من
السعوديين بالاضافه الى تواجد ايضا حاله
سعوديه للاسف بتعمل ابلاغ عنها بانها
موجوده تحت الانقاض يتم العمل
بالتنسيق بين السلطات السعوديه والتركيه
على البحث عن هذه السيده السعوديه التي
تبلغ من العمر خمسين عام خلال تواجدها في
هذا هذه البنايه وعمليه البحث مستمره عن
هذه السيده عدا ذلك كل السعوديين
والسعوديات تم اجلائهم مباشره وعددهم 45
البعض منهم غادرت غادر هذه المدينه اضنه
مباشره الى الاعلان عن نقود واحد سعودي هو
من السفاره عبد المحسن
نعم بالفعل تحدثت قبل قليل مع السفاره
وقالوا بانهم تلقوا بلاغ من اهل هذه
السيده بتواجدها في هذا المنزل تواصلوا
مباشره مع السلطات التركيه للبحث وهم
يعملون مع السلطات التركيه في في المنطقه
التي وقع بها هذا المنزل بحسب بلاغ
العائله لهذه السيده وحتى الان يتم عمليات
البحث
والاجلاء وحتى عمليات البحث عن هذه السيده
في هذا المنزل الذي انهدم بشكل كامل
وعمليات التنسيق بحسب القائم بالاعمال
السعودي هنا في انقره مع السلطات التركيه
بالاضافه الى تواجد مندوب من السفاره وعدد
من العاملين في السفاره بذلك الموقع
لمتابعه هذه العمليه عمليات البحث لهذه
السيده حتى الان لم يتم العثور على اي شخص
في هذه المنطقه سواء كان السيد السعوديه
والبنايه التي انهدمت او غيرها من
الاشخاص الذين كانوا متواجدين ولكن عمليات
البحث مستمره وعمليات ايضا التاكد من
تواجد هذه السيده في هذه المنطقه
يجري لانه البلاغ الوحيد الذي بلغ ان
السيده موجوده في هذا المنزل هو من اهلها
وبالتالي تم التحرك من قبل شكرا في انقره
لاغاثه او اخراج هذه السيده
العربيه من اضنه في تركيا
[موسيقى]
يلا براءه
يلا يلا
يا شباب
يا الله
وصلت كما اشرنا قبل قليل قبل ساعات البعثه
السعوديه المشاركه في اغاثه متضرريه
الزلزال الى مطار اضنه في تركيا وكانت
السعوديه اطلقت الجسر الجويه لاغاثه
المتضررين بدءا بطائرتين سعوديتين اتجهت
فجر اليوم الى مطار اضنه محملتين بمساعدات
طبيه واغاثيه وعلى متنهما ايضا فرق اسعاف
وانقاذ متخصصه ويتواصل التضامن الدولي مع
ضحايا الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا حيث اعلنت
عده دول فتح جسور جويه لنقل المساعدات
الانسانيه الحمله السعوديه لاغاثه متضرر
زلزال جمعت حتى الان نحو 120 مليون ريال
نتابع معكم هذه الصور من تجهيزات الاليات
اليات ومعدات فرق الدفاع المدنيه السعودي
في مطار الملك خالد الدولي في الرياض
تمهيدا
لارسالها الى
مطار اضنه في تركيا عبر طائره خاصه وضمن
حمله المساعدات التي على مثل السعوديه
ينضم الينا المشرف العام على مركز الملك
سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه الدكتور
عبد الله ربيع دكتور عبد الله حياك الله
معي في نشره الرابعه اذا وصلت اول طائرتين
ضمن الجسر السعودي
المخصص لمساعده متضررين الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا وصلت الى مطار اضنه اولا الدكتور
عبد الله ما هو تقييمكم الاول او التقرير
الذي وصلكم رب عن حجم الاحتياجات
والمساعدات المطلوبه في بعض المناطق
المنكوبه
مرحبا بك اخي خالد وبشاهد العربيه حجم
المساعدات او حجم الاحتياج الانساني الذي
وصلنا الى الان حجم كبير جدا
وصلت بعض الاحتياجات من قبل سفاره التركيه
في الرياض وكذلك من قبل المنظمات المعتمده
في تركيا وكذلك المنظمات التي تعمل معنا
في سوريا
والاحتياجات كما يعلم الجميع تتركز في
المراحل الاولى الاحتياج الكبير
للمختصين في الانقاذ
ورفع كذلك ما تم من هدم المباني والمنازل
فهنالك حاجه للكوادر البشريه المختصه في
الانقاذ وكذلك الكوادر البشريه المختصه في
التدخل السريع والتدخل الطارئ والكوادر
الطبيه المختصه في الاصابات بالاضافه الى
احتياجات
الانسانيه كبيره تتركز في الايواء والمواد
الايوائيه وكذلك المواد والمستلزمات
الصحيه
الادويه
والغذاء وكذلك التغذيه للاطفال الصغار
السن هذه هذا الحجم كبير جدا ومتنوع ويضم
مناطق متعدده في كل من سوريا وتركيا ولكن
كما اشرت اخ خالد الطائرتين وصلت وكذلك
وصل اكثر من اربعه وخمسين من المختصين في
التدخل السريع وكذلك الكوادر المختصه في
الطوارئ وطب الاصابات هي الان موجوده على
الارض وكما اشرتم في التقرير هنالك 94 من
المختصين السعوديين الذين لديهم شهادات
ترخيص في الانقاذ من المدير العامه للدفاع
المدني سوف تقلع خلال وقت قصير جدا ليصبح
مجموع المشاركين من السعوديه قرابه 148
شخص على الارض
ويتبعهم ان شاء الله فرق اخرى متخصصه
بالاضافه الى ان الطائره الثالثه الان
تجهز بالمواد الاحتياجات سواء لوائيه او
الطبيه او الغذائيه وكذلك نجهز الطائره
الرابعه وسوف تستمر او يستمر هذا الجسر
الجوي
بناء على ما يقوم به الفرق الميدانيه
حاليا من ضمن المتواجدين على الارض فرق
مختصه في تقييم الاحتياج الانساني
الفرق لديها خبره كبيره جدا في اعاده
تقييم الاحتاج الانسان بالتنسيق مع منظمات
المحليه والدوليه والامميه
الى اين توجه هذا الفريق ما هي المناطق
التي لها الاولويه الان ضمن هذا الفريق
السعودي دكتور عبد الله مع من يتم التنسيق
في تحركاته
بالنسبه لتركيا معروفه ومحدده وتم التنسيق
فيها مع السلطات التركيه وبالاخص منظمه
ايفاد
والهلال الاحمر
التركي بالنسبه لسوريا كذلك تم تنسيق مع
الجهات والمنظمات المختصه الهلال الاحمر
السوري كذلك المنظمات التي نعمل معها سواء
كانت محليه او عموميه لدينا مجموعه من
المنظمات التي يعمل معها مركز الملك سلمان
منذ سنوات وتم التواصل معهم
وهنالك تنسيق على مدار الساعه مع تلك
المنظمات وقيادات تلك المنظمات لضمان وصول
المساعدات وكذلك تخفيف معاناه المصابين
بشكل العاجل من خلال الفرق الميدانيه
الموجوده على الارض حاليا في ادمه وغازي
عنتاب
سمحتي بس تصحيح
ذكرت ان الحمله الشعبيه وصلت الى 120 الان
وانا اتحدث معك وصلت الى قرابه 145 مليون
استجابه جدا
كريمه ووفيه من الشعب السعودي بتوجيهات
القياده الحكيمه
الفرق ما الموجوده الان على الارض دكتور
عبد الله ما هي طبيعه عملها
وبالنسبه للمعدات اللازمه ايضا او المطلوب
توافرها معهم
ليعملوا ضمن الفرق الموجوده على الارض في
انتشال الانقاذ في المباني المهدمه
سؤال جيد خالد اولا فيما يخص الانقاذ تم
بناء على التقييم الاولي اخذ الاجهزه
الضروريه الاساسيه من قبل المختصين
والرجال الذين لديهم شهادات معتمد الدوليه
تحمل الطائره اجهزه مختصه في الانقاذ
والتدخل السريع بالنسبه لفرق التدخل الصحي
والطب الطوارئ وطب الاصابات تم كذلك حمل
الاجهزه والمستلزمات والان الفريق وانا
اتحدث معك يبنون المراكز الصحيه ومراكز
الطبيه في الميدان لتبدا الفرق الطبيه
بالعمل
والتدخل لمعالجه الاصابات وكما يعلم
الجميع الكسور وما في حكمها
كان هنالك مجموعه من الكوادر الصحيه
السعوديه المتطوعه التي
شاركت مركز
وهيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي
للسفر مع الطائرات الطائره الاولى
والثانيه وهم الان موجودين في الميدان
ونتوقع خلال الساعات القليله ان يبدا
العمل للسعدي سواء كان انقاذ ورفع
الانقاض عن المصابين او كذلك علاج من تم
اخراجهم في المراكز الصحيه الميدانيه التي
يقيمها او تقيمها الفرق المختصه من مركز
الملك سلمان اعمال الانسانيه وهيئته
الاحمر السعودي
دائما في مركز الملك سلمان تؤكدون على
مبدا للعمل الانساني وهو ماكدت عليه ايضا
في تصريحاتك الاخيره بان العمل الانساني
للسعوديه لا يرتبط باي اجندات دينيه او
سياسيه لكن من يتابع هذه الازمه دكتور
خلال هذه الايام يرى الكثير من التصريحات
والمواقف الدوليه التي تبدو لاي متابع لها
متناقضه الكل كل طرف يحمل الطرف الاخر
المسؤوليه ويطالب بعدم تسييس هذه
المساعدات الان
ما هي الاليات دكتور عبد الله بالنسبه
للمركز التي تضمنون من خلالها وصول هذه
المساعدات المنكوبين والمتضررين في
المناطق المتضرره خصوصا في سوريا دكتور
شكرا خالد على هذا السؤال اولا لعلي اؤكد
من خلال شاشه العربيه ان العمل الانساني
السعودي هو عمل انساني بحث غير مرتبط باي
اي جند سياسيه دينيه عرقيه ولذلك الفرق
التي ذهبت توجيه التي لديها العمل لرفع او
لمساعده المحتاجين من هذا الزلزال دون
النظر للموقع او المكان او كذلك اي دوافع
اخرى بالنسبه لما يصدر من جهات او دول او
منظمات نحن لا ننظر اليه نحن نعمل كما كنا
نعمل في السابق مع عدد كبير من المنظمات
الامميه والدوليه وكذلك
المنظمات الغير ربحيه في سوريا الموثوقه
نعمل معهم
وبدانا بالفعل منذ ان صدر التوجيه الكريم
بالتواصل معهم ولنا موثوقيه عاليه في هذه
المنظمات التي نعمل معها ولدينا اليات
رقابه لضمان ان العمل الانساني السعودي
يصل للمحتاجين بصرف النظر عن مواقع
تواجدهم
ايضا في تصريح لكم قلتم بان المركز لم
يستقبل التبرعات النقديه والعينيه
فقط اريد التاكيد على الرقم الاخير الذي
ذكرته دكتور بانه المبالغ التبرعات
الماديه وصلت الى قرابه 145 مليون ريال
الان قلت بانه سيتم اعتماد التبرع الرقمي
لضمان مامونيه المال عن طريق منصه ساهم او
موقع المركز الالكتروني والسؤال هنا عن
كيفيه الاستفاده ايضا من هذه المبالغ مبال
التبرعات لمساعده المتضررين كيف ستكون
لضمان شفافيه ومامونيه المال الذي يقدم
تبرع من المحسنين ورجال الاعمال واهل
الخير فلذلك المركز الحريص على الشفافيه
والرقابه الماليه ولدينا رقابه ماليه
عاليه
ومحاسب خارجي وكذلك جهات رقابيه داخل
المركز وخارجه بالنسبه لكيفيه الاستفاده
من هذا المال
بكل تاكيد سوف
فريق التقييم الموجود على الارض الان يرسل
لنا ولدينا لجنه تعمل على مدار الساعه
الاولويات والاحتياج الانساني العالي
وبناء عليه يتم
تحويل هذه الاموال بناء على الاولويات
الانسانيه سواء كانت غذائيه او ايوائيه او
صحيه
ولله الحمد نطمئن المتبرعين ان هذه
التبرعات تصب في انقاذ حياه بشر تحت
الانقاذ فان شاء الله ان الاجر عند الله
كبير جدا لهؤلاء تؤكد دكتور عبد الله ان
هذه المساعدات سواء كانت من خلال هذه اتين
الطائرتين او الطائرتين الثالثه والرابعه
التي ايضا ستصل ربما في وقت لاحق ستصل الى
كل المناطق
المنكوبه في في سوريا وانت تعلم ماذا يعني
هذا الامر تحديدا في ظل النزاع الموجود في
هذه المنطقه
صحيح
لكن المركز وشركاء المركز لدينا تعليمات
واضحه ان نصل لكل المحتاجين سواء كانوا
الاشقاء السوريين او الاشقاء التركيين
دكتور هل لبستم اي عوائق من اي نوع امام
ايصال هذه المساعدات نتابع هذا الامر منذ
بدايه هذه الازمه والحديث حول يعني دمار
في الطرق تعقد مساله وصول المساعدات
بالاضافه الى مسائل لوجستيه اخرى
ماذا وصلكم حول هذا الامر والى اي مدى
يمكن ان تعيق من وصول المساعدات وهل من
مساعده تبذلونها في اصلاح هذه العوائق او
ازالتها دكتور من خلال المركز
اولا طبعا لا زلنا نجمع المعلومات من فرق
التقييم التي ارسلها مركز الملك سلمان لكن
المعلومات التي وصلت للان هنالك عوائق بلا
شك كما ذكرت خالد في الطرق كذلك المعابر
ولكن
الموجودين من الزملاء على الارض والعاملين
في المركز
مصرين على ايصالها بشكل سريع ومن ضمنها
مساعده السلطات الميدانيه على فتح هذه
الطرق وهذه المعابر بشكل سريع جدا وايصال
هذه المساعدات باسرع واقصر الطرق لتصل
للمحتاجين لتخفيف هذه المعاناه الانسانيه
الكبيره التي يواجهها الشعبين السوري
والتركي شكرا جزيلا لك المشرف العام على
مركز الملك سلمان لغاته والاعمال
الانسانيه الدكتور عبد الله ربيع
شكرا
ونتابع معكم لنا هذه الصور الخاصه من
مدينه حارم السوريه في ادلب وهي احدى
المدن المتضرره جراء الزلزال
اتبع هذه الصور حارم هي احدى المدن
المنكوبه في سوريا
في ادلب تحديدا حجم الدمار كبير للكثير من
المباني المتضرره جراء هذا الزلزال مباني
هدمت تماما سويت بالارض مباني اخرى
طالعه ايضا الدمار الجزئي ربما فرق
الانقاذ المتوفره البسيطه كما نشاهد
المعدات كذلك الثقيله الموجوده على الارض
الان تقوم بجهد كبير في محاولات منها
لانتشال الجثث او مساعده العالقين تحت
انقاذ هذه المباني
المدمره في ضوء الارقام الاخيره ايضا
المرصوده حول
القتلى او المصابين جراء هذا الزلزال الذي
دمر اجزاء كبيره من الجنوب التركي ومن
الشمال في سوريا
ينضم الينا الان السفير التركي لدى
السعوديه فاتح سيد فاتح اهلا وسهلا بكم
معنا
تعزينا اولا
للضحايا
وكذلك للدمار الذي نشاهده الان يعني ربما
في هذه الصور من سوريا وكذلك من مناطق
كثيره في الجنوب
التركي سيد فاتح اولا كيف تم التنسيق مع
سلطات السعوديه في مساله هذا الجسر الجوي
الاغاثي السعودي
الجزيره الشكر على تعزيكم وعلى تضامنكم
معنا
هذه هي هذا الزلزال الذي فاق بقوته 7.5
في منطقه
كهرمان في تركيا
هناك دمار كبير وهذه وهذا الزلزال
اثر على منطقه واسعه جدا وهي الشد
ولم يسبقها سوى واحده قبل ثمانين عاما
ولا وهناك فرق كبير بينهما وهو
اننا
تعرضنا لزلزال لين متتاليين خلال تسع
ساعات ومن ثم
الهزات الارتداديه التي شهدناها وكان
عددها كبير جدا
وبناء على بيان من الرئيس
الف قتلوه
و6000
من المباني انهارت وبالتالي
تم ارسال فرق اغاثه الى المناطق من وزاره
الدفاع ومن مختلف المؤسسات بدات بالعمل
اللازم
وتم اتخاذ الاجراءات مع كل المؤسسات
المعنيه منذ وقت الزلزال واليوم
31 محافظ
يعملون في منطقه
الكارثه تحت تنسيق
كامل
ومع التنسيق كامل
فسيكون يوم حداد حتى
حتى الثاني عشر من فبراير
سيكون يوم حداد
وسيتم ارسال العمليات الطبيه في الوقت
الراهن
115 الف فرق انقاذ
يشاركون في هذه العمليات
تم ارسال ايضا فرق لمساعده الاسر من اجلي
ايجاد البلد الامن والحمايه من احوال
الطقس القوات المسلحه تقوم
بمشاركه في عمليه الاخلاق
18 الف واكثر يشاركون في هذه العمليات
وقوات الجويه
والفرق الطبيه والبحث والانقاذ كلهم
يعملون وايضا فيلق الهندسه وغيرهم
يعملون
ويقدمون كل الخدمات في منطقه كهرمان
28 الف تم اخلائهم من المناطق التي تعرضت
للزلزال في مثل هذا الوضع فان الراي العام
قد يكون
مؤثرا على الوضع وبالتالي من المهم
[موسيقى]
اخذ المعلومات من الجهات المسؤوله مثل
الوكاله
التركيه
الرسميه المسؤوله عن الاحصاءات وعن نشر
المعلومات المتعلقه بالزلزال
وبالنسبه للدعم الخارجي من اشقائنا في
السعوديه
نسلط الضوء على اننا ممتنين جدا لهذا
الدعم وتضامن من المملكه ومن شعبها
خادم الحرمين الشريفين وسمو الامير محمد
بن سلمان
سمو ولي العهد الذين وجهوا بالغ التعازيه
لرئيس اردوغان
وسمو الامير ولي العهد والرئيس الوزراء
محمد بن سلمان
اجرى اتصال مع الرئيس اردوغان
فرق بحث واخلاق وانقاذ تم ارسالها من
السعوديه الى تركيا وحسب توجيهات القياده
فقد اطلقوا
حمله جمع تبرخ تبرعات من خلال
مركز لجمع التبرعات لارسالها
للمحتاجين ونحن نشكرهم ونقدر لهم هذا هذه
الوقفه في مثل هذا الوقت
الدعم مهم جدا من الدول الشقيقه والسعوديه
واحده من هذه الدول الرئيس
اردوغان سمى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه التي
تدعم وتواصل دعمها لتركيا في هذا الوقت
العظيم ونحن نتطلع الاستمرار تعاوننا في
هذا الاطار
وتم ارسال خطابات التعزيه من مختلف
المناطق السعوديه الى تركيا سيد فاتح
ملاليات
التي اتفق عليها ونتحدث هنا ربما مع
الجانب السعودي خصوصا بشان ضمان وصول هذه
المساعدات المستحقيها وربما اكون يعني
احدد المساله هنا في في اطار وجهتها نحو
الاراضي السوريه
ارسلنا
قائمه من المواد التي نحتاجها
لمؤسسه الاغاثه مؤسسه الملك سلمان للاغاثه
وايضا وزير لوزير الخارجيه السعوديه
كل هذه القوائم تم ارسالها لتضم كل المواد
التي نحتاجها في مناطق الزلزال وهي ما
نطلع المملكه عليها بشكل فوري ولكل
السلطات البانيه اما بالنسبه لسوريا
فللاسف
فان اثر
هذه هذا الزلزال على في الشمال الغربي
فهناك
ممثلين
للمعارضه اتصلوا بعدد من الدول بما فيها
تركيا
وطلبوا بارسال مساعدات دوليه الى المنطقه
وجزء من سياساتنا الخارجيه الانسانيه
اعلنا عن استعدادنا لتيسير وصول هذه
المساعدات الانسانيه لوصولها الى شمال
سوريا
واي حمله انسانيه
تخص تركيا
وسوريا لابد ان تتم من خلال التنسيق التام
مع السلطات التركيه المعنيه والسفاره في
الرياض
ارسلنا معلومات للسلطات السعوديه حول
الطرق
ومعابر التي يتم فيها ايصال المساعدات
السلطات التركيه مستعده للتعاون مع كل
الشركاء وكل ما يحاولون المساعده وخاصه
السعوديه لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
شمال السوريه شكرا جزيلا
شكرا جزيلا لك السفير التركي لدى السعوديه
فاتح
اظهر مقطع فيديو سوريين مدنيين يتطوعون
لمساعده عمال الانقاذ التابعين للخواذ
البيضاء اثناء بحثهم عن ناجله تحت انقاذ
المباني المناره في قريه بسنايا في محافظه
ادلب
[موسيقى]
معلش معلش يا خالو معلش
متابع معكم تغطيتنا تنضم الينا من دبي لان
هاله غريط المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الامريكي سيده هدى اهلا وسهلا بك معي في
على شاشه العربيه في هذه التغطيه نريد ان
نستودع حقيقه ما يحدث الان معك السيده
هاله حول
المساعدات الامريكيه تحديدا هل وصلت هذه
المساعدات اين وصلت ولمن تقدمه
شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه وقبل ما نبدا
لازم اقدم تعزينا للشعب التركي لسفير
التركي ولشعب السوري نحن كلنا نرى هذه
الصور والصعب جدا
كامسانه يعني صعب جدا نرى هذه الصور وقلوب
الشعب الامريكي كله مع الشعب التركي
وسوريا الان وبالنسبه للدعم الامريكي في
نقطتين هنا
منذ منذ بدايه الحرب الولايات المتحده
تدعم سوريا والشعب السوري دعمنا الشعب
السوري باكثر من 15 مليار دولار في دعم
انساني وفي هذه السنه ارسلنا كثير من
الدعم الانساني ولذلك عندما حصل الزلزال
المنظمات غير حكوميه كان عندهم دعم من
الولايات المتحده دعم من دعم مساعدات
الغذائي مساعدات الصحي وكذلك مساعدات
للاماكن للحمايه
بعد الزلزال اخذوا هذا الدعم الامريكي
واستعملوه
ليساعدوا الشعب السوري على طول مباشره
بوقت سريع جدا هذه اول نقطه انه كان في
دعم امريكي داخل البلد وهذا استعمل تحديدا
ملتزمه بالشعب السوري وبالشعب وبدعم الشعب
التركيه الاثنين وارسلنا فراق بعثوا
الانقاذ الى تركيا ولكن كذلك ارسلنا اليات
وادويات ادويات للحفر
ومختصين الاليات مختصين بالبحث والانقاذ
وهذا راحل تركيا وكذلك الى سوريا وايضا
ارسنال متخصصين في البحث والانقاذ
كثير من الخبراء مثلا مهندسين
مسعفين كذلك
وهؤلاء
المتخصصين روحيل تركيا وكذلك الى سوريا
بعد الزلزال يساعد الشعب السوري ومن تاكيد
انه الوكاله الامريكيه الدوليه للتنميه
ستلعن ستعلن باكثر دعم للشعب السوري
وللشعب التركي القادمه لان مع الاسف
الكارثه وكله يغير يوم يوم ورا يوم
والولايات المتحده ملتزمه بالدعم الشعبين
في هذه الكارثه
الى اين وصلت هذه المساعدات تحديدا في
الاراضي السوريه
بالنسبه لتحديدا ممكن اقول في الاماكن
لمحتها
للناس محتاجينها ولكن بالسبب امنيه لا
يمكنني اقول
بفين بالضبط ولكن وزير بلانكين قال امس في
مؤتمر صحفي مع ناظره من حلف النيتو قال في
المؤتمر انه هؤلاء الخبراء راحوا الى
الاثنين سوريا وتركيا هذه هذه المعلومات
اللي عندنا
وبالتاكيد انه الشعب السوري يعرف انه
الولايات المتحده تقف جانب الشعب السوريه
الان مثل خلال سنوات الاخيره خلال منذ طول
الايام الحرب نحن نعمل كل في جهودنا وكما
قلت الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه
يوسع اي دي هي هذه الوكاله مسؤوله بكل
المساعدات ولكن كمان عندها تنسيق مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي مع وامم المتحده مع كثير
من المنظمات غير حكوميه داخل سوريا
وكذلك مع الجيش الامريكي في اوروبا يعني
كل التنسيق
لنبحث كل طرق الايجابيه لوصول الدعم الى
تركيا الى سوريا والى تركيا اذا كنت فهمت
كلامك بشكل صحيح
قد تكون هذه المساعدات وصلت الى المناطق
التي لا يسيطر عليها النظام او تسيطر
عليها
المعارضه ولكن تصريحات التي تاتي من هناك
ربما تشير الى عكس ذلك تماما بانه لا
مساعدات وصلت حتى الان اذا ما اخذنا بهذا
الامر بهذا الشكل وعدم تحديدك للجهه التي
وصلت اليها
المساعدات الامريكيه الان هل يعني ذلك ان
هناك من يعرقل وصول هذه المساعدات الدوليه
من اي طرف كان الى الاراضي السوريه سيده
هاله ومن هي هذه الجهه
انا ممكن اكون واضحه جدا في هذا السؤال
الولايات المتحده تشتغل مع المنظمات غير
حكوميه داخل سوريا والمنظمات غير حكوميه
داخل سوريا يشتغلوا في كل اماكن داخل
سوريا مثلا
حوض البيضاء تشتغل في كل الاماكن ليس فقط
في اماكن
من غير النظام
والخود البيضاء تروح لفين الناس محتاجينها
والولايات المتحده تدعم سواد البيضاء
ومنظمه غير حكوميه اخره ولكن الولايات
المتحده لا
نواصل اي دعم بالشكل تماما الى النظام لان
نحن نعرفه من كل الايام كل السنوات
الاخيره انه ليس هناك اي ثقه في النظام
اذا الدعم يروح الى النظام
سيكون فساد سيكون صرك ولازم نفكره انه
النظ مستعمل اسلحه كيماويه ضد الشعب
السوري والان الولايات المتحده
تشوف طرق فعليه ايجابيه كيف ممكن تساعدو
الشعب السوري بالشكل قوي والشكل الفعالي
ولذلك نحن نشتغل مع المنظمات غير حكوميه
داخل سوريا في كل في وهما عندهم اماكن
عندهم
ايجابيات لروحوا المكان المهمه داخل سوريا
ونحن عندنا ثقه وعلاقه قويه مع هذه
المنظمات غير حكوميه ونحن نواصل الدعم
لهذه المنظمات النظام السوري يقول بان
قانون العقوبات يعيق وصول هذه المساعدات
للسوريين بشكل عام سواء كان يراد نظام او
في غيرها كيف تردون وتعلقون على هذا الامر
زيدان
مع الاسف هذا كلام النظام السوري ولكن في
دليل نرى انه
طيارات وعلى اخري
روحوا الى دمشق يعني في كثير من البلدان
اختاروا دعم الى الى الحكومه الى النظام
الاسد ليس هناك اي تاثير من الحكومه
الامريكيه ليس هناك اي رد الفعل من
الحكومه الامريكيه
القانون
العقوبات واضحه واضحه جدا منذ سنوات انه
الدعم الانساني ليس هناك اي تاثير على
الدعم الانساني بالنسبه للعقوبات في
استثناءات لدعم الانساني لدعم الغذائي او
الصحي او على اخر كل الدعم الانساني هناك
استثناءات تحت العقوبات وفي دليل انه
يواصل دعم للنظام والولايات المتحده ليس
عملت اي شيء ضد هذه البلدان
طرق طريق النظام
ما هي المعابر التي تستخدمونها لايصال هذه
المساعدات للسوريين سيده هاله كل
المعلومات الان منذ بدايه هذه الازمه وحتى
الان تشير الى عدم جاهزيه مثلا معبر باب
الهوى لاسباب متعلقه
باللوجستيه متعلقه مثلا بدمار يحيط في هذا
المعبر في تصريحات اخرى تقول بان هذا
المعبر جاهز هناك معابر اخرى مثل السلام
والراعي كذلك من يقول بانها جاهزه هل هذه
هي المعابر التي تدخل من خلالها المساعدات
الامريكيه وغير الامريكيه وهل يتم التنسيق
مع الدول الاخرى الراغبه في تقديم
مساعداتها للسوريين خاصه في الاراضي التي
لا يسيطر عليها النظام
صحيح انه الزلزال كان عنده تاثير كبير على
المعابر وعلى باب الهواء وهذه كانت مشكله
كبيره
وعلى طول الولايات المتحده كانت على اتصال
وفي التنسيق مع الامم المتحده والشركاء في
الارض في الارض الواقع وكذلك مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي كان في تنسيق قوي لنبحث على على
الطرق الفعاليه اللي ممكن الدعم يدخل
وبالنسبه للولايات المتحده ومع تنسيق مع
المنظمات غير حكوميه داخل سوريا كنا نبحث
على اي جهه ممكن الدعم يدخل ولكن سمعنا
اليوم من الامم المتحده اخبار ايجابي انه
الامم المتحده
حصلت الدعم
عبر باب الهوى اليوم او المره من بدايه
بعد الزلزال وهذا كان خبر جيد جدا ولكن
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده هذه النكته
نحن كنا نكلمها من سنوات انه لازم توسيع
الحدود لازم توسيع المعابر الحدود
لسعد السوريين والنظام مع الاسف كل هذه
سنوات كان ضد هذا ولكن هذه النقطه مهمه
الولايات المتحده دائما تشجع توسيع الحدود
في شمال
لمساعده للسوريين من ينسق عمل
الخبراء والمختصين ومساله ايصال المساعدات
يعني طرف امريكي موجود على الارض هل
السفاره او القنصليه في تركيا عادت لعملها
لانه هناك معلومات تتحدث عن اغلاق السفاره
قبل اسبوع من الان تقريبا وصححي لي هذا
الامر
بسبب دواعي امنيه
الرئيس بايدن عين السمان هي مديره وكاله
الامريكيه الدوليه للتاميه هي المسؤوله
قائده
لتنسيق كل الدعم للولايات المتحده
لمساعدات لسوريا وتركيا وهي تشتغل مع كل
الجهات المعنيه داخل الحكومه الامريكيه
لان فيه جهات كثيره داخل الحكومه
الامريكيه ليس فقط الوكاله ولكن الخارجيه
الوزارات الدفاع يعني الفراق البحث
والانقاذ جو من ولايه كاليفورنيا وولايه
فرجينيا هذا يظهر انه كل الولايات المتحده
تعمل كل في جهودها
لوصول الدعم للولايات المثاليه لسوريا
وكذلك
في تركيا ابوابها العدد لمتابعه اعمالها
حتى
بالنسبه للمعلومات اللي انا عندي ممكن
ارجع لك بالتاكيد في هذا ولكن بالنسبه
للمعلومات اللي عندي
السفاره ليس مغلوقه للسفاره بتشتغل
والسفير هو لقبل صفر سفير امريكي في في
انقره في في تركيا هو اللي استقبل الفراق
البحث والانقاذ اللي وصلوا من امريكا اذا
المشاهدين يريدوني
يشوفوا يرى الصور للبحث
للفراط بحث الانقاذ ممكن يروحوا الى تويتر
يشوفوا الصور للفراط بحث والانقاذ
الامريكي لوصل الى تركيا وكل الاليات اكثر
من 77 كيلو جرام من اليات ليساعدوا بالفحر
ليساعدوا بالبحث والانقاذ والولايات
المتحده كما قلت نحن نعمل كل في جهودنا
والشعب التركي والشعب السوري وفعلا قلوبنا
مع مع شعبان شكرا لك من دبي هاله غريت
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
نتابع منها
عمار الهندي اهلا بك عمار ما هي اخر
المستجدات والتطورات
خالد من قصه الى اخرى للبحث عن الناجين
كنا صباحا يعني تتبعنا مع قصه الاشخاص او
العائلات التي لا تزال تحت الانقاض واخراج
شخص ما زال على قيد الحياه هنالك قصه اخرى
على الجانب الاخر من هذا الشارع نتتبعها
ان كنت تشاهد هذه البنايه خالد هذه لم
تسقط ولكنها اصيبت من الزلزال بشكل كبير
وواضح يعني انا ساطلب من الزميل ان يقترب
بالكاميرا حتى اريك المشهد بشكل كامل هذه
البنايه لديها تسويه وفيها ثلاث اشخاص
سوريين
بالامس قام احد احد اقربائه بالاتصال مع
مع شخص منهم واجاب على الهاتف بانهم احياء
وبعدها
الهاتف كان لا يزال يرن ولكن لا يجيب
اليوم جاء فريق انقاذ اردني لديه جهاز فحص
حراري وتبين بان هؤلاء الاشخاص منهم احياء
وبالتالي الان عمليات الانقاذ تجري في هذه
ولكن مع تحذير
لمقاطعتك الان ساذهب لمتابعه هذه الكلمه
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب توفي فيها 962
تقريبا وايضا هناك مئات الجرحى
على ارواح الذين توفوا بسبب هذا الزلزال
ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل
للجرحى والصبر والسلوان لاهاليهم
[موسيقى]
دوله مصر
والقوات المسلحه وفرق الانقاذ وفرق انقاذ
التابعه لاداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
بالاضافه الى
فرق الانقاذ التي وصلت الى هنا من انحاء
العالم الجميع يساهم هنا في عمليه البحث
والانقاذ طبعا بسبب انتشار هذه الكارثه
الى منطقه جغرافيه واسعه فهناك بعض
التحديات التي نواجهها ولكن
المواطنه التركيه يعرف جيدا ان الحكومه
التركيه موجوده بكل مواردها هنا في هذه
المنطقه
وقعت والاف انها تشاركون في اعمال البحث
والانقاذ منهم متطوعين ومنهم رسميين ومنهم
ايضا من العالم تم ارسال مئات الالات
والمساعدات الى منطقه
الزلازل هذه هو الان في البرلمان يتم
تمرير قرار حاله الطوارئ واعتقد انه سيتم
اعلانها خلال ساعه تقريبا بعد ان يتم
تصويت عليها بعد ازاله هذه الانقاض باذنه
تعالى سنكمل عمليه اعاده الاعمار في هذه
المدن
كما تتذكرون استطعنا ان نعيد الاعمار في
مدينه
فنز
وتشجيع
كل هذه
نجحنا في اعاده اعمارها بعد الزلازل ايضا
بعد حرائق موضه
ان نعيد الاعمار وايضا بعد السيول
والفيضانات التي اصبت مدينه
[موسيقى]
التي اصابتنا لذلك انا اود ان اذكركم مره
اخرى مؤسسه الاسكان التركيه ساب تعيد
الاعمار هنا بدعم من الحكومه التركيه
وخلال هذه الفتره
سيتم تقديم 10,000 ليره تركيه لكل اسره
لندعمها
مادياستخدمونها في هذه الفتره بشكل مؤقت
الى ان يتم
اعاده الاعمار هنا واعاده عدد الحيوانات
الى طبيعتها واهم خطوه هنا او احد اهم
الخطوات هنا قبولا
نقوم بالنقل انا جينا من هذه الزلازل الى
مدن انطاليا والانيا ونستضيفهم في الفنادق
بشكل مجاني
والخطوط الجويه التركيه
تخصص الرحلات الجويه المجانيه لنقل
النجينه من هذه الزلازل الى هذه المدن
شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]
هذه كلمه الرئيس تركي رجب طيب اردوغان في
زيارته الى احدى المناطق المتضرره جراء
الزلزال في جنوب تركيا نعود الى هاتاي الى
موفد العربيه عمار الهندي اعود اليك عمار
تفضل تابع
نعم خالد
فحر فحر تسمعني عمار
اسمعك نعم نعم اسمعك خالد كنت تتحدث عن
هذا المبنى الذي تقف امامه الان صحيح
الاستمرار جهود الانقاذ
صحيح كنت اشرح لك قصه مؤثره في الحقيقه
لثلاث شبان سوريين
وهذا التجمهور هناك هم طبعا يعني حذروا
مرارا وتكرارا انه لا يجب ان يتواجد هناك
سوى فرق الانقاذ لان هذه البنايه ستنهار
في اي لحظه لانه ما يحدث هناك خالد هي
عمليات انقاذ لثلاث شبان سوريين على في
التسويه هذا المبنى
ما حدث بان احد اقربائهم اتصل باحدهم تحت
الانقاض واجاب على الهاتف واخبره بانهم لا
يزال احياء هذا يوم امس وبقي الهاتف يرن
حتى مساء امس اليوم جاء فريق انقاذ اردني
لديها اجهزه حراريه فحص المكان واكد بان
هنالك احياء داخل المكان وبالتالي
العمليات بدات يعني هنالك اقربائهم
واخوانهم يعني يعني يساعدونا في اخراجهم
ولكن المشكله الحقيقيه يعني ادق عمليه
انقاذ اراها هي هذه خالد لانه البنايه هذه
قد تسقط وتنها في اي لحظه في حال اي خلل
وهم يعملون تحت الانقاذ في تسويه هذا
المبنى المؤثر جدا بانه احد هؤلاء الشباب
جاء من اسطنبول ليله الزلزال
ليكتب كتابه ليتزوج هنا من شابه سوريه
ولكنه يعني ما لحق وفي نفس الليله حدث
زلزال وللاسف الان هو تحت الانقاض
القصص يعني كثيره ومؤثره طبعا هنالك حاله
من الانهيار لدى اقربائه هناك يعني يعني
انا شاهدتهم يعني بشيلوا الحجاره بطريقه
هستيريه يعني لانهم يريدوا الوصول الى
هؤلاء الاشخاص تحت الانقاض طبعا العمليات
عمليات البحث عن الناجين في كل هاتاي
مستمره المساعدات تصل تباعا عبرها طائرات
عسكريه يعني كل دقيقه تمر طائره مروحيه او
عسكريه من فوقها اي نعم خالد شكرا جزيلا
لك عمار الهندي من العربيه
اذا في نهايه هذه الساعه نذكر باخر
الارقام نحو 20,000 قتيل في تركيا وسوريا
بسبب الزلزال رئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
قال بان تركيا تستضيف او نستضيف المتضررين
من الزلزال في الفنادق بشكل مجاني
وايضا تحدث
الخارجيه الامريكيه قالت او طالبت بزياده
المعابر الحدوديه لايصال المساعدات الى
السوريين
واكدت بان العقوبات على سوريا لا تعرق
الوصول للمساعدات للشعب السوري
واشارت او قالت بان
واشنطن لا تثق في النظام السوري لايصال
المساعدات للمحتاجين او المحتاجين عفوا
وان هناك عمل مستمر مع المنظمات غير
الحكوميه في داخل سوريا لدعم الشعب السوري
وان الولايات المتحده كذلك وحسب تصريحات
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الام
ملتزمه
بالدعم وتقديم المساعده للشعبين السوري
والتركي بعد هذا الزلزال التغطيه المستمره
الى ميسون عزه